S
BASICALLY HANGING ON THE LINE
AFTER THE FALLOUT FROM
PARTYGATE.
HERE'S THE RESULT, WE'LL LISTEN
INTO GRAEME BRADY.
>> AS RETURNING OFFICER, 359
BALLOTS WERE CAST.
NOTE --
THE VOTE IS IN FAVOR OF HAVING
CONFIDENCE IN BORIS JOHNSON,
THERE WAS 211 VOTES.
AND THE CASE OF 148 VOTES.
THEREFORE, I CAN ANNOUNCE THAT
THE TORY PARTY DOES SUPPORT
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE] >> THERE YOU HAVE IT,
THE NUMBER OF VOTES WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY I WASN'T ABLE TO
HEAR THE EXACT NUMBER.
CAN SOMEONE SHOW ME EXACTLY,
PAST ME THAT, 211 VOTES TO
2:48.
THAT AS AN EXTRAORDINARY HIGH
NUMBER OF VOTES AGAINST BORIS
JOHNSON.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT WHETHER
THERE WOULD BE 50, 90, 105,
110.
BUT 211 VERSUS 2:48.
NEARLY HALF OF HIS MPS ARE
AGAINST HIM.
DAVID LURE ME, I'M TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THOSE NUMBERS ARE
CORRECT.
BLANCA NOBILO IS DOWN THE
STREET --
>> YES, RICHARD, THE NUMBERS
ARE CORRECT.
211 IN FAVOR OF THE PRIME
MINISTER, 148 AGAINST.
THAT'S OF THE 359 BALLOTS, ALL
THE CONSERVATIVE MPS NONE
SPOILED.
HE WON, BUT HE WON BADLY.
>> SO, 148.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE HIM,
BIANCA?
>> THAT LEAVES HIM IN AN
UNCHAINED POSITION OF POLITICAL
PERIL, THAT ISN'T A SIGNIFICANT
VICTORY, REALLY WHAT WE'D BE
LOOKING FOR IN ORDER TO
STABILIZE HIM IN HIS POLITICAL
POSITION, IS TWO THIRDS OF HIS
OWN MPS SUPPORTING.
I'M BATS WHAT HAPPENED TONIGHT
--
I THINK THAT'S WORSE THAN
TERESA MAY SHOWING, EITHER WAY
THE PRIME MINISTER ESPECIALLY
THIS ONE, WHO'S CONSIDERED TO
BE THE CONSERVATIVE PARTIES,
ONE OF THEIR BEST VOTE WINNERS
IN HISTORY.
HE DELIVERS AN 80 SEAT MAJORITY,
THROUGH A SERIES OF UNFORCED
ERRORS, AND LEADERSHIP FAULTS,
SCANDALS, PERSONAL
DECISION-MAKING, WHICH IS OWN
MPS DISAPPROVE UP.
HE'S LANDED HIMSELF IN THIS
POSITION, WHEN THAT ALMOST NONE
COULD'VE EXPECTED WHEN WE
DECLARED THE ELECTION VICTORY
RESULT BACK A FEW YEARS AGO,
RICHARD.
>> RIGHT, THANK YOU BIANCA
NOBILO, --
148 VOTED AGAINST HIM.
DAVID LAM EASE WITH ME, BRITISH
LABOR MP, YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY IN
OPPOSITION, YOU'RE GONNA SAY
YOU SHOULD GO I'LL GIVE YOU
THAT ALREADY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> AND WE'LL LOOK, HE'S DONE
WORSE THAN MARGARET THATCHER
DAD'S BACK AGAINST TIME.
HE'S THE WORST THAN THERESA MAY
DID IN 2018.
AND HE'S DONE WORSE THAN JOHN
MAJOR DID BACK IN 1995.
SO, THIS IS A STAGGERING AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE, IF YOU THINK ABOUT
BORIS JOHNSON AS 160 MPS ON HIS
PAYROLL ANYWAY THAT ARE GONNA
VOTE FOR HIM.
HE'S DONE VERY, VERY POORLY.
>> YOUR LEADER SAID IT'S THE
BEGINNING OF THE END.
OBVIOUSLY YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
BUT HOW SOON IS THE END?
>> AS NIGHT FOLLOWS DAY, HE'S
NOW GOT TWO BY-ELECTIONS, HE'S
GOT A PARLIAMENTARY TO FACE,
AND I'M AFRAID WE'VE GOT HIGH
INFLATION, A LARGE AMOUNT OF
THE MPS DON'T TRUST THEM.
HE'S IN TROUBLE.
>> YOU NEED A BETTER LEADER TO?
YOU NEED A LEADER, PARASITIC
ARE NOT, IF YOU HAD A STRONGER
LEADER YOU WOULD BE IN A
STRONGER POSITION.
>> WE CAME OUT OF THE LOCAL
ELECTIONS IN A STRONG POSITION.
WE'RE AHEAD IN THE POLLS, WE'VE
BEEN CONSISTENTLY FOR MONTHS.
THE LABOUR PARTY, VERY GOOD
POSITION RELATIVE TO WHERE WE
ARE IN 2019.
BUT THIS TONIGHT IS ABOUT THE
CONSERVATIVES.
>> I AGREE.
>> THIS IS ABOUT THE
CONSERVATIVES, VERY VERY CLEAR
THAT HIS BACK BENCHES ARE NOT
WITH THEM.
HE'S DOOMED.
YOU CANNOT SURVIVE.
>> SO, I KNOW AGAIN, I REALIZE
YOU'RE NOT IN THE TORY PARTY
BUT HE'S GOT A YEAR AT LEAST.
BECAUSE HE CANNOT BE --
ACCORDING TO THE CURRENT RULES.
>> I THINK THE WAY TO SEE IF
THOSE HUNDRED 48 MPS ARE GONNA
GET --
THEY'VE GOT NOTHING TO LOSE.
THIS BILL STATE THEIR
INTENTIONS, THEIR ASSOCIATIONS
PRESUMABLY ARE WITH THEM.
AND SO, FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS IT'S VERY CHOPPY RATHER
FOR THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY, AT
A TIME WHEN THE BRITISH PUBLIC
WANT YOU TO SOLVE THE COST OF
LIVING CRISIS.
>> GOOD TO HAVE YOU SIR, GREAT,
I GUESS FROM YOUR PARTY'S POINT
OF VIEW, IT'S HOW YOU HANDLE
THE PRIME MINISTER WHO'S
CLEARLY ON THE ROPES, HOW --
>> WILL CONTINUE TO DO, WE'VE
BEEN SAYING BORIS JOHNSON
SHOULD LEAVE SOME TIME.
THE LABOR PARTIES IN THAT PLACE,
THE PUBLIC'S THERE, ARE NOW
CONSERVATIVE BACKBENCHERS HAVE
JOINED US.
THIS IS A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE
FOR BORIS JOHNSON.
>> GOOD TO HAVE YOU SIR, THE
FORMER SPECIAL ADVISORY TO THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY, SHE IS WITH
ME NOW.
SO, I GUESS THE PHRASE DEAD MAN
WALKING, IS THAT BORIS JOHNSON
TONIGHT?
>> I CERTAINLY THINK THAT HE'S
WOUNDED, AND WOUNDED VERY
BADLY.
148 MPS, YOU RECALL AS A WORSE
RESULT THAN THERESA MAY, AND
MAJOR, WE WANT EVERYONE TO GO
BACK THAT FAR.
THIS WILL HAPPEN CERTAINLY HAVE
BEEN ON THE WALL PESSIMISTIC
ESTIMATE FROM BORIS JOHNSON
SUPPORTERS WHO I THINK, WE'RE
HOPING FOR AROUND 120.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT VOTE
FROM CONSERVATIVE MPS.
>>, I'M LOOKING AT THESE
NUMBERS THERE IS MORE THAN 40%
VOTED AGAINST BORIS JOHNSON.
IF HE WISHED, TURN IT AROUND,
LET'S ASSUME IT'S POSSIBLE YOU
CAN DO THAT.
AS YOU SAY, THE NUMBERS ARE
HEAVILY AGAINST HIM LOOKING AT
PAST PRESIDENT OF OTHER PRIME
MINISTER, TORY PRIME MINISTERS.
BUT WOULD HE HAVE TO DO?
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
THE REALITY IS, HE IS GOING TO
TOUGH IT OUT, I CAN'T SEE A
SCENARIO WHERE THE PRIME
MINISTER DECIDES TO WEIGH,
WITHOUT LOOKING AT A RESHUFFLE
TO SORT OF RESET HIS TOP TEAM.
ALTHOUGH FROM THOSE NUMBERS,
AND MIGHT INDICATE THAT ALL THE
PAYROLL, I.E. THE MINISTERS --
WITH THE PRIME MINISTER.
I THINK THERE MIGHT BE QUIET TO
PUBLICLY DECLARE THIS --
YOU MAY WISH TO RESHUFFLE TO
REWARD THE LOYALISTS,
ESSENTIALLY THOSE AND
DISCOURAGE THE OTHERS.
I THINK WE COULD SEE SOMETHING
LIKE A GOVERNMENT RESHUFFLE,
CERTAINLY SOME BIG SPEECHES TO
RESET THE PM'S --
THERE ARE STILL HUGE, HUGE
BOULDERS AHEAD BECAUSE THERE'S
BY-ELECTIONS COMING IN JUNE,
THE VOTE ON WHETHER THE PRIME
MINISTER HAS LED THE HOUSE,
WILL BE A COMMITTEE REPORT THAT
WILL LIKELY BE VOTED ON.
THERE'S LOTS, AND LOTS OF
PERILOUS MOMENTS AHEAD.
>> WHICH BEGS THE QUESTION, IN
TERMS OF POLICY, THE WAY THE
GOVERNMENT NOW FORMULATES
POLICY.
I KNOW IN THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS
WORKING HERE NONSTOP, IT'S
ABOUT DELIVERY, IT'S NOT ABOUT
THIS, IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT, IT'S
NOT ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED TO DELIVER.
BUT CAN HIS PARTY, YOUR PARTY
DELIVER?
>> YEAH, IT'S A GOOD QUESTION
ABOUT POLICY.
PART OF THE CONSIDERATION FROM
SOME OF THE MPS I SPOKEN TO, IS
A QUESTION AROUND NOT JUST THE
PARTIES AND THE PM'S CONDUCT
BEHIND THE SCENES DURING
LOCKDOWN.
BUT ALSO THE QUESTION OF HOW DO
WE AS A PARTY, AS A GOVERNMENT,
AS A COUNTRY WHETHER SOME OF
THE HUGE STORMS THAT ARE AHEAD.
WHEN WE LOOK AT INFLATION,
UKRAINE, ENERGY CRISIS, THESE
ARE BIG ISSUES THAT REQUIRE
REALLY BIG SWINGS.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WILL BE,
HOW MUCH CAN YOU BRING, WHEN
YOU'VE GOT A MAJORITY AND YOU
WANT YOUR MPS NOT